PROFESSOR: So let's think
of a specific virus,
the coronavirus, including
the case of interest today,
which is the SARS-CoV-2
novel coronavirus.
So this virus comes
in the form of virion,
which is the capsid
containing RNA, which
is then going to infect a cell.
And the size of that virion is
around 120 nanometer diameter,
and it's nearly
a perfect sphere.
Now, the size here of 120
nanometers compared to bacteria
is about 1,000 times
smaller than [some] bacteria.
So this actually has
a very big implication
in terms of how a virion can
be spread from one organism
to another.
So the bacteria,
if you recall, are
the size of several microns.
That's the scale of large
droplets, which sediment --
or larger than that,
they would begin
to sediment out of the air.
And we can think about
transmission through coughing.
Also, besides the fact that
the virus is much smaller,
it cannot swim.
So bacteria have various
means of locomotion -- cilia,
flagella, et cetera, whereas
the virion essentially
is a little hard sphere.
So how can a virion
actually transmit itself?
Well, if we draw
a droplet, which
is released by
respiration, then the virus
is actually extremely small, at
the scale of typical droplets
that come from respiration,
which, as we've discussed,
have a typical, most
probable size around half
a micron, and then
have mostly droplets
that are larger than that.
So at that scale, if we think of
this as a micron scale droplet,
this little virus
is extremely small.
It's like a little
point, essentially.
And so a single droplet may
contain a couple viruses,
a couple virions.
And so in order for the
virion to escape the droplet
and make connection
with a cell in a host,
let's say it's been breathed
in, and in the lungs,
it's going to try to
meet with some cell
and begin to infect it.
Or conversely, if the virion
is being shed and released
from an infected
cell and then needs
to go into a droplet to
then be exhaled and spread
to somebody else,
either way, the virion
has to get in and
out of this droplet.
And since it cannot swim,
the only way can do it is
by essentially a random
walk or a diffusion process,
where it's just bouncing around
due to thermal fluctuations.
And eventually, at some
point, it gets out.
So the diffusion process -- we
can estimate the typical time
to escape.
I'll write it this way --
[it] can be shown if the
radius of the droplet
is R, the average
time for a randomly
distributed and selected virion
anywhere in this droplet,
the time for it to escape is
of order R squared over D,
where D if the diffusivity.
And if you do a precise
calculation for a sphere,
then there's a
factor of 15 here.
And so that is basically average
escape time by diffusion.
So that gives you a sense
of how quickly the virion is
able to get out of the cell --
or out of the
droplet, excuse me.
Now, how big is the diffusivity?
Well, the diffusivity
of the virus,
if you think of it just
as a fluctuating sphere
in a viscous medium, then we can
use the Stokes-Einstein formula
for the diffusivity,
which is k_B*T,
where k is Boltzmann constant
and T is the temperature.
So k*T is the thermal
energy of the fluctuations.
And that's divided by 6*pi
times the radius of the virus,
and then the viscosity
of the liquid or fluid
containing the droplet.
So essentially, this
denominator here
is the Stokes drag coefficient
for a sphere fluctuating
in a viscous medium.
So that's the diffusivity.
And if you figure out for the
size of 120 nanometers, if we
use the viscosity of water, if
we assume the droplets are just
water, then this is
3.6e-8 centimeters
squared per second
in water, where
we use the viscosity of water.
But the droplets
are not just water.
In fact, they cannot be.
As we've already discussed,
water droplets at this size
range would very quickly
evaporate and disappear,
or they would leave
the virus essentially,
a virion no longer
contained in such a droplet.
So what's more typical is
that the droplet in fact
contains many
macromolecules and is
coming from mucus in the
pharynx, in the vocal cords,
coming from the lungs directly.
And mucus has a much
higher viscosity.
So notice, here, we
have the viscosity
of the liquid coming in.
And if we take into
account the fact
that the viscosity of mucus
relative to the viscosity
of water is roughly --
it depends where the
samples are taken
and also what's the shear rate.
So we're talking
about low shear rate.
These are sort of moving slowly.
The viscosity of
mucus is dependent
how quickly you're shearing it.
But if it's a low shear rate,
then this is on the order of
1e3 to 1e5 at low shear rates.
And because the viscosity
has that factor,
the diffusivity is then
divided by that factor.
So what that's telling us is
instead of being around
1e-8 centimeters
squared per second,
we're really looking at
more like 1e-11
1e-13 centimeters
squared per second in mucus.
So we assume these are
actually mucus droplets, which
are not fully evaporating and
are contained in aerosol form,
then this is the
kind of diffusivity.
And if we plug into
this formula here,
we can get a sense of what is
the average time for the virion
to actually escape.
So why don't we make a
little table of that result.
So let's look at the radius.
First, let's consider here 0.5
microns, or 500 nanometers.
So that would be a
1-micron diameter droplet.
So that would be kind of a
typical aerosol droplet coming
from breathing.
Let's also consider
larger droplets.
So let's look at
5 microns, which
is kind of on the upper
end of the aerosol range.
And then we could
look at 50 microns.
And I should say this
is R of the drop.
So the R here, just to be
careful, is they R of the drop,
as opposed to the R of
the virus, which is R_v
is half d, so that's
60 nanometers.
OK, so that's the diameter.
So this is the different
size of the drops.
And just for comparison, let's
look at water versus mucus.
And from mucus,
why don't we take
that the viscosity of the
mucus is 1e4 times
the viscosity of water?
So we just pick something kind
of in the middle of this range.
OK, well, if we plug
in then the numbers
and we try to plot the average
escape time that I've just
written here, R^2/(15*D),
then in water,
this turns out to be
about 5 milliseconds
for an aerosol droplet.
So we know the aerosol droplets
are evaporating quickly
and also that a
virus can diffuse out
of it relatively quickly,
because the water is not
really that this.
Now, if we move
in this direction,
we're multiplying R by 10.
And notice, the time scale
goes like R^2.
So there is a pretty
strong size dependence.
So as we think of a 10
times larger droplet,
it's 100 times longer time.
So that would be 500
milliseconds, or 0.5 seconds.
And if we go another
factor of 10,
that's another factor
of 100 in time.
And if we convert
seconds to minutes,
it turns out to be
around 8 minutes
for a fairly large drop.
Now, what if we're in a mucus?
So now, we go in this direction.
The timescale goes like 1/D, and
D goes like 1 over viscosity.
So the timescale is
proportional to viscosity.
So we're getting this
factor of 1e4.
That's a pretty big factor.
And so, for example, this
5 milliseconds for mucus
can turn into 1 minute.
So from an aerosol
droplet, which
is sort of at the most probable
size from respiration, which
is on the order of a
little bit below 1 micron,
a typical virion would
take about a minute
to diffuse out of that droplet
and infect a nearby cell
or tissue.
Now, if we look at a little bit
bigger droplets, this 1 minute,
we multiply by 100,
it's 100 minutes, which
is on the order of 1.5 hours.
And what if we keep going
another factor of 100?
That turns into around 7 days.
So if the virion is contained
in one of the larger droplets
that comes from
coughing or sneezing,
it could take it hours to days
to escape from that droplet
and have any chance of
infecting a host cell.
So you can immediately see
the problem for a virus
in terms of transmitting
is it can't swim.
It's extremely small.
And so it's not a good
way to transmit itself
to be sitting in a large
droplet or a pool of liquid,
imagine a pool of
saliva or some phlegm
that you've just
coughed up, which
is very common for
bacterial transmission.
For a virus, it's
much more difficult
for a significant amount of
virus to actually get out.
So if the virus is going
to transmit itself,
it makes a lot more sense
to be in aerosol droplets.
And so it's really here,
the aerosol droplets
are the most infectious,
because basically,
the virus able to get out.
And based on this
calculation, roughly speaking,
if R of the droplet, which
we're just calling R,
if R is less than
around 5 microns,
those are the ones
we would expect
to be the most infectious.
And interestingly
for SARS-CoV-2,
recent experiments have sampled
droplets from sick patients
with COVID-19 at
different sizes.
And it was found that
the droplets that
had a diameter less
than about 4 microns
were the most infectious
and clearly you
could see replication
of the viral RNA
in samples of those
droplets, whereas larger
droplets in this
range here, kind
of larger than a few microns,
were less infectious.
And in fact, the virus was
less able to replicate.
So it's kind of consistent
with this physical argument.
So basically what we
would probably say
is that in this range, the
virions are mostly trapped.
They have a hard time
getting out of those droplets
and can deactivate over time,
because that's also happening.
They are believed to have
a certain finite lifetime.
And so this is the
case that the virions
are trapped and deactivate in
large drops or the fomites,
which are infectious residues
on surfaces that are left over
from those droplets.
So this really shows
us that our focus
should be on looking
at aerosol droplets
for viral transmission.